DNA is the genetic material in every
cell that is passed from generation to
generation. Each cell has a lot of DNA,
and it needs to be organized to make it
easy to inherit. But how is your DNA
organized? DNA in cells exists in
discrete units called chromosomes. Each
chromosome is made up of one very, very,
very long piece of double stranded DNA
that has thousands of genes. Your cells
have 46 chromosomes and they come in
pairs, 23 that you inherited from your
biological mother and a matching pair
of 23 chromosomes from your biological
father. Thus, most of your genes come
in duplicates, a copy from mom and a
copy from dad. If you accidentally
inherit one too little or one too many
chromosomes, consequences can be severe.
For example, Down syndrome occurs when
you have three, instead of two, copies
of chromosome 21. One pair of
chromosomes is unique and is involved
in determining your sex. If you inherit
an X chromosome from mom and an X from
dad, you are a double X and acquire the
characteristic traits of a female. If
you acquire the puny little Y
chromosome from dad then you are an XY
and become a male. Different organisms
have different numbers of chromosomes.
Some plants have hundreds of
chromosomes, and some ants have only
one pair. In addition to their role in
heredity, chromosomes are a way of
packaging a long string of DNA in a
small, small space. In animals, fungi,
and plants, DNA is stored in a membrane
structure called the nucleus. If we
blow up a nucleus 10,000 times its
size, then it would fit half the width
of this paper. On this scale, your DNA
in total would be 20 kilometers long,
and would have to fit into this space
without getting tangled. In chromosomes,
special proteins called histones act
like spools to wrap and help neatly
package DNA. Want to learn more about
how chromosomes are inherited? See our
videos on mitosis and meiosis.